a former bachelor contestant reportedly  killed  authorities tell ET a plane went down  Monday in the Los Angeles area  according to local police it was a  single-seat aircraft and it caught fire  a construction crew working nearby  pulled the female pilot from the plane  an eyewitness told KCBS the pilots legs  were on fire  the pilot was taken to a hospital in  full cardiac arrest and did not survive  Us Weekly identified that pilot as Aaron  storm a contestant on season 12 of The  Bachelor she competed in 2008 when Matt  grant appeared as the bachelor she was  eliminated during week 3 of the show and  ET has a statement from Grant he tells  us quote massively shocked devastated  for her family and friends we were lucky  to have Aaron on season 12  she was genuine a self-assured beautiful  and hilarious